well good afternoon and it's a pleasure
to be able to introduce Howard Davies
who will talk about his new book banking
on the future the fall and rise of
central banking they're really two
reasons two primary reasons why this is
a very important and happy occasion and
one is that we have gladys columbia a
very very close relationship with lse
and that partnership which includes
joint degrees joint faculty and other
projects has really been very very
successful often these kinds of deep
networks don't work out so well in this
case it's really been a great success
also want to recognize David Weinstein
and Columbia's program for economic
research which David directs for being
our partner on this and David will come
up afterwards and help moderate
questions the second reason why this is
a great occasion is because Howard has a
wonderful background and a wonderful
mind to be able to think creatively and
clearly about this incredibly important
subject of central banking and its role
in global finance and business and his
his experience you can read about I've
had the pleasure of talking to him on
several occasions about this and and he
II and reading his op-eds and other
things and he he brings to the subject I
think enormous great good sense and a
lot of intellectual creativity I frankly
would say if you'd asked me 10 years ago
or before that whether central banking
is as sexy as it appears today I would
have said no I really don't think that
that central banking is is that kind of
a big issue for the Society of the world
well it's certainly become that and I
think that those of us who who watch the
economy in this country and then observe
and and participate in perhaps the
development of a global economy see this
as one of the top two or three issues of
the time just how are we going to take
this incredible spread of capitalism and
markets and finance which has so many
benefits for the world but also a lot of
issues and problems how are we going to
take this and and make it realize its
potential and use the institution's we
have and invent new institutions reshape
the ones we have to to bring that about
this is a this is a mammoth an
incredibly important challenge and I
think the ignorance that most of us have
and I include myself in this despite the
fact that I serve on the New York
Federal Reserve Board the ignorance that
exists in the society and in the world
about central banking is something that
we just have to overcome so this little
event here in the scale of world events
is one step in in that direction how
we're really really happy to have you
here as a partner as a collaborator and
as a fellow scholar Howard Davis
well thank you very much lean and thank
you for this invitation though I
suddenly find myself in some
embarrassment because i have to say i
thought i was speaking at king's college
because I I don't recall that you have
actually ever asked formally for
permission to change your name and from
the Privy Council and so the British
instruction is that that's how I have to
describe you the partnership you
describe is a very important one to us
at the lse we have several double
degrees we have an MPA program and it's
been moving ahead I think extremely well
indeed we're also collaborating on
something called economists online which
is an attempt to get economists to put
all their work on a kind of central
online database and that's another
initiative that the LSC in europe and
columbia in the US have pioneered and it
looks as though it's spreading quite
well so this is a great partnership and
under lighted bits and this event this
evening can help solidify it and indeed
it's a kind of return match because
earlier on this year Lee came inspected
Lee lse to launch his latest book on the
free press and that was a terrific event
as well so I'm hoping that we can keep
up with these events there's also
another link actually which I was
reminded of when I spoke to my son last
night between innings at Yankee Stadium
where I was a sad event for New Yorkers
and he said he said what are you doing
in New York that's what I'm speaking of
columbia tomorrow night he said huh I
didn't you should do that so I said why
and I'd completely forgotten that just a
few months ago at Columbia turned him
down now at this point Lee is thinking
how can I invited some guy who's going
to stand in the low library and complain
about an admission decision in relation
to his son but this is not quite my
point at
because my son reminded me that the
previous time he'd been turned out seven
years ago was in fact by the LSE in my
first year as director which as you
could imagine went down very well in the
family now at this point some others of
you are thinking how on earth can this
man use his sons embarrassment to amuse
an audience in the beginning of a
lecture but the I should therefore say
that when he was turned down with the
lse he was in fact over the place and
took it up by Oxford and when he was
turned down by Columbia he was in fact
offered a place at Harvard so he's fine
but what it shows is that the LSC and
Columbia have similarly extraordinarily
high admission standards and the
selectors have similarly fine judgment
in my view now it's a good moment for me
actually to be out of the United Kingdom
because the government have just
introduced a huge program of expenditure
cuts including very large cuts to
universities including to the lse so
this is a very good opportunity for me
because I know from reading the
newspapers that Columbia now owns most
of Manhattan and I'm going to propose to
Lee later that if you can just raise
another city block and find a little
corner for the lse we may well move
right over here now let me however pick
up his challenge to try to tell you
something about central banking and the
book that I've recently published was
conceived actually before the crisis and
the point was really to look at the way
in which central banking had been
evolving and to do so from an insider
outsider perspective my co-author David
Greene spent 35 years in the Bank of
England I was deputy governor of the
Bank of England and then we both moved
to set up the Financial Services
Authority in 97 taking a large chunk of
the Bank of England with us and our
was to try to integrate some of the
academic thinking about central banking
and the techniques of monetary policy
and the techniques of oversight of
financial markets and try to integrate
that with our own experience and
perspective of how central banks
actually worked and we were very pleased
and flattered that we had good access to
the central bankers most of whom we knew
one way or another so we spent a lot of
time with Ben Bernanke and jean-claude
trichet and others who were very
generous with their time though of
course nothing we say can in any way
commit them and so the book attempts a
broad survey if you like of central
banking really going through what
central banking is through monetary
stability and indeed right up to the
kinds of people who need to lead central
bank so I thought they're probably the
best thing to do for you this evening
was to go through these 12 topics I
think sort of 20 minutes or so on each
will probably be be enough but actually
to save you that fate worse than death
I'm just going to focus on really two
subjects the first of all the first one
is this complex of issues relating to
the role of monetary policy and macro
prudential oversight in other words how
far should central banks think about
asset prices the growth of credit how
should they interact with the way we
regulate banks and particularly the
capital requirements on banks this is
still a very controversial question and
indeed those of you who read the
Financial Times will have noticed an
article about a rather public spats just
in the last few days between jean-claude
trichet the ECB and axel day by the head
of the Bundesbank taking very different
views on how financial stability should
be brought into the objectives of the
ECB this is also very controversial in
the UK and the second topic that I'd
like to cover is the particular
phenomenon of economic and monetary
union and it's a which is a particular
and I think rather interesting example
of the relationship between
central banking and politics in europe
which i think is perhaps not quite as
well understood over here as it might be
and in each case i'll try to take the
debate on from what's in the book to
bring it up to date with current
concerns now to give you the overall
thesis that we try to advance in this
book it is that central banks came to
focus too narrowly on retail price
inflation and in the last in the 15
years or so leading up to the crisis
became somewhat monetary policy
Institute's if you like rather than
broad central banks that they tended to
neglect credit growth and what was
happening on asset prices and what
actually went on in financial markets
Charles good heart one of the lsi's most
distinguished financial economists said
of the Bank of England model recently it
excludes everything I'm interested in in
terms of the way in which monetary
policy operates through financial
markets now there are those who agree
with us and I think that Adrian and shin
of Princeton do and argue strongly in a
recent paper that's bringing financial
institutions back into the heart of
monetary economics is crucial and indeed
the Bank of England is now beginning to
say this as well but this is not still
yet i think the dominant thinking in
central banks and there are very big
issues about how to integrate financial
stability in a framework of monetary
policy but let's begin by just looking
back a little at what went on in the
run-up to the crisis and of course part
of the story was the huge current
account imbalances which developed and
this is I think an important starting
point for an understanding of what went
wrong in our financial systems as a
matter of fact I have just published
another book called the financial crisis
who's to blame which canvases 38
different explanations for the crisis
which I have discovered obviously it
would be simplest just to say who's too
just to say Goldman Sachs you know why
not and someone who is actually also
director of Morgan Stanley that seems
quite a convenient explanation to me but
in fact I think we have to begin with
what went on in global the global it
macro economy and we saw this huge
growth in global current account
imbalances with the China and the oil
exporters in huge surplus and the US and
the UK want to do other countries in
huge deficit at we also saw a relatively
weak monetary policy the red line is the
deviation of the feds interest rates
from the Taylor rule the Taylor rule as
you probably know is a way of describing
the reaction function of central banks
in relation to the inflation rate and
capacity utilization and tends to
describe a kind of neutral interest rate
policy when I was on the monetary policy
committee at the Bank of England we
would tend to look at the Taylor rule to
see where we were in relation to a kind
of neutral interest rate policy and and
Don Taylor has argued whether
strenuously that the Fed following the
2001 calm boom and bust kept interest
rates low for quite a long time and
didn't raise them until somewhat too
late this debate is a very lively one
John Taylor himself has pointed to clear
evidence of monetary excesses during the
period leading up to the housing boom
Greenspan continues to respond that it
was long-term rates and not the
overnight rate of central banks that
were important then it does seem to me
and that the Fed did influence the yield
curve all the way up and the the
combination of this relatively weed
monetary policy and the global
imbalances did lead to a significant
mispricing of risk as will come on to
see and there were lots of other
evidence of imbalances and of expansions
at an unsustainable rate in the
financial economy
if you look at bank balance sheets the
expansion of leverage was quite
remarkable during this period that's the
US banking system and it wasn't just in
the US if you look at UK banks bank
leverage grew very rapidly from about
the end of 2002 I particularly like this
chart because I stopped being the UK's
financial regulator in the middle of
2003 and clearly that's when things
started to get out of hand but this was
a quite remarkable growth in leverage
and one which the central banks did not
respond to and risk as a result became
seriously mispriced I mean one
convenient measure of this I think is
the JPMorgan global high yield index
which for a long period for 20 years
traded as an average of 542 basis points
above us treasuries and by the June 2007
it was little more than 250 basis points
and this was really a very sharp change
and is I think one convenient
representation of the mispricing of risk
during this period at the same time of
course we saw large increases in asset
prices real house prices rose very
sharply not just in the United States
indeed you can see quite a number of
places where they rose even more rapidly
to some extent this was a function of
economic and monetary union in Europe in
some of these countries long-term rates
came down very sharply because of the
joint because of joining EMU and that
did deliver a one-off uplift to house
prices but this was a fairly common
trend although not as you can see at all
in Germany and practically not at all in
Switzerland but certainly in the US and
the UK and some of the peripheral
countries of Europe we looked as if we
were seeing a very dramatic increase in
house prices and household debt
rose sharply I find Americans often
rather surprised to discover that the
plucky Brits actually beat you in terms
of indebtedness Americans like to think
that they are the consumers of last
resort and are second to none in terms
of taking on unsustainable leverage but
you know we were right there and as you
can see we were slightly above you so we
saw massive expansion of credit rapid
escalation of asset prices huge global
imbalances significant mispricing of
risk and what were the central bank's
doing while this went on well they were
writing financial stability reviews this
is the number of countries publishing
financial stability reviews during the
decade from 1995 to 2005 I should say
and I say this without huge pride that I
invented financial stability reviews
because the first one was a bank of
england one which i introduced when i
was deputy governor in order to try to
defend the bank of england's role in
banking supervision after the bearings
collapse where we felt that we ought to
show that we were interested in
financial stability and thinking about
the issues in financial markets because
we knew there was a threat that the
government would take banking
supervision away from us threat which
actually did crystallize in spite of the
financial stability review though now as
these things turn around it's now going
back into the bank of england i should
really have patented the name i would
have made quite a lot of money out of it
but while central banks were writing
financial stability reviews it didn't
seem to be doing very much on the basis
of them and indeed there's quite a lot
of evidence that these reviews which
were meant to cover developments in
financial markets and identify risks to
stability were in fact very sanitized
indeed the IMF have done an interesting
example of all of the indicators of
financial stress that in fact the IMF
had
and suggested that people should cover
and there are about 40 of their about 40
of these indicators and they have assess
the extent to which these are covered by
financial stability reviews and in many
cases they are simply not and in all
cases they are missing some of them and
interestingly the database shows that
central banks that were banking
supervisors as well as monetary
authorities were less candid in their
publications in in relation to the
volume of indicators that they produce
than ones who were not supervisors
suggesting that if you are a supervisor
you are somewhat constrained in what you
can say about developments in the
financial system because obviously
people will say well if that's really
worrying the supervisor gosh we really
ought to be worried about it so there's
an interesting divergence there between
the central banks who are supervisors in
central banks who are not the ones who
are find it more difficult to admit
what's going wrong so what you could see
during this period is that although
there was an outpouring of publication
of our financial stability it did not
lead to any action why is that the case
well there is of course a difference a
complicated relationship between price
stability and financial stability price
stability is quite easy to measure of
course economists can talk endlessly
about that their precise definitions of
retail price index but in broadly
speaking it's quite easy to measure the
instrument that control is well
relatively well understood there are
arguments about lags but we broadly have
a reasonable understanding of how
interest rates and the transmission
mechanism work it's quite easy to devise
accountability for price stability you
can define your inflation target as many
countries do and the Fed is sort of
creeping in the direction of being an
inflation target oh now I think and you
can hold your governor to account for it
the forecasting structure is relatively
straightforward you're focusing on a
central tendency with some variation and
some
risks around it forecasting well you may
or may not get it right but the
procedures have been well worked on over
the years and administrative ly it's
quite a simple thing to do actually it's
quite easy to change interest rates
central back to know how to do that much
of this does not apply to financial
stability typically if you look at
definitions that people have advanced it
tends to be defined by what it isn't it
tends to be defined by the absence of
unpleasant events the instrument for
control is quite difficult now we may be
developing a better instrument in the
future in the form of variable capital
ratios but it quite difficult to adjust
and with unpredictable lags and
unpredictable effects we do not know
that much about how changing capital
requirements in banks for example
affects behavior and affects the cost of
credit very difficult therefore to hold
people accountable for it because very
difficult to define what it is you're
trying to achieve and your forecasting
really is more interested in the tails
of the distribution than the central
tendency because the tails are where the
mischief lies and that is inherently a
much more difficult thing to do and you
tend to be doing stress tests and
simulations which are also you know
difficult techniques to play around with
and it's also quite administratively
difficult now we conclude that in order
to make financial stability a reality
the central bank needs a robust set of
indicators of financial stress the IMF
has produced some but I think they're
probably generally regard is not yet
adequate this is work in progress in the
bis and elsewhere but we still don't
have that I think we still do not have a
set of traffic lights of financial
stress that people are prepared to agree
to and prepared to use as a tool of
policy we need of course to identify
systemically important firms that is
happening now at the g20 indeed has even
been announcement of progress on that
today but it's I think difficult to be
totally sure what you mean by
systemically important
firms and therefore in our view you need
to be always patrolling the regular tree
frontier what do I mean by that well I
think we have discovered in this crisis
that there are firms which are or have
been outside regulation which can also
be systemic ltcm was obviously one
example more than a decade ago of an
institution unregulated but which did
threaten to create significant problems
in the financial system and I think that
the financial stability Oversight
Council that we now have in the u.s. is
actually rather a good model in this
respect because it does have under
dodd-frank the ability as it were to
cease institutions which may currently
be outside regulation and bring them in
if it believes that they have become
systemically significant and the central
bank I think also does need to be
involved in counter cyclical
requirements whether the central bank
needs to be the banking regulator I
think is a moot point so these are what
i think the central bank needs to work
on and then that brings us to the sort
of argument that people have is it well
even if you have all of this is it right
on occasions to lean against the wind of
asset prices and credit creation even
when your retail price inflation measure
is looking okay and i think that in my
view the answer to this is yes I don't
think central banks should target asset
prices I do think however asset prices
need to be brought in to inflation to
some degree but I do think that it is
possible to think imaginatively and to
think in an anticipatory way about
credit bubbles and react and I think
that what we have learned from this
crisis is that the argument that used to
be advanced particularly by Alan
Greenspan that the best thing a central
bank could do with was mop up after the
event that does not seem to me to be a
sustainable argument in the
right of the value destruction that we
have seen in this crisis and paying some
insurance premium upfront when you
identify potentially dangerous trend
seems to me to be better than simply
waiting until the end but of course the
question is how do you do it do you do
it only through monetary policy or do
you need some other weapon well at the
moment the fashionable thing is
macro-prudential policy in other words
this is the new new thing in thinking
about how to influence the financial
system that not only do you want to
regulate financial institutions looking
at their risks but you need to look at
the system as a whole and have a macro
prudential approach to setting capital
requirements and the b is produced a
report on macro-prudential policy which
identified that some of the the
securitized assets which apparently had
superior liquidity were actually risk
generating assets and this was as if you
like the internet in intellectual
rationale for macro-prudential policy
but actually it's not so new as all that
because that report was actually written
in 1986 and all of the things that
happened this securitized assets and the
transfer of risk and how that generated
risk in fact occurred at 25 years later
or 20 years later and in the meantime
that not a lot had been done to generate
this framework of macro-prudential
policy and we still had procyclical
capital regulation with the way in which
capital regulation was set was a look at
a-put bank's portfolio today and play
back into the past the point at which it
would have lost the most money and used
that as the basis for your capital which
of course can at the limits tell you if
the market is really at a peak that just
before the market collapses the model
tells you don't need any capital at all
so we clearly have to correct that floor
and we have to try to find a way of
using the capital requirements in a more
flexible way so where do we come out on
all of this well our view is that a
narrow focus on retail price inflation
can deliver sub optimal outcomes that
there is a persuasive case I think for
leaning against the wind of credit
bubbles but a lot more is needed on the
practicalities we think that financial
stability should be a statutory
objectives of the central bank in the UK
that has now been legislated and I think
it's a good thing elsewhere because the
central bank if it's going to take
awkward decisions to raise interest
rates or tighten capital requirements at
a time when the skies are blue then it
will need a good excuse for doing so and
it will need to be able to look to an
obligation in order to justify its
action which may not seem immediately
justifiable in relation to short-term
inflation we think that a macro
prudential mechanism is a useful
additional tool but and here is where we
differ significantly from current
thinking actually in the Bank of England
we think it must be looked at alongside
the short term interest rate because
both of them work through the price of
credit and you do need to think about
these two things alongside each other in
the UK we now have the odd situation
where there is a monetary policy
committee in the Bank of England and a
financial policy committee meeting at
opposite ends of the corridor and but
they are both looking at mechanisms
which can have the same effect on credit
and the economy as far as central banks
of supervision is concerned well this is
a fraught debate around the globe we
think the case for the central bank
being the direct supervisor is unproven
and indeed if you look at what has
happened in the crisis the case for
integrated regulation is stronger than
ever now in the in the u.s. essentially
you've tried to meet this gap by giving
the Fed a sort of license to Rome
if you like through the financial
stability Oversight Council which may be
one solution if you cannot achieve
better regulatory integration but I
think it's a second best solution and
recently Chairman Bernanke came to the
LSC and I made these points to him and
he laughed but there you are you can
only do your best now that's slightly
unfair we actually had a very good
debate but I do think that at the moment
there are still some quite big issues
about just how central banks are going
to respond in future to credit growth
which we still haven't got to the bottom
of but let me move quickly to my second
topic economic and monetary union which
i think is unfinished business and the
MU crisis which we have been living
through for the last six months or so is
I think another train crash that was in
fact seen coming and the proposition
here is that the EU set up a single
currency without the supporting
mechanisms that you need in order to
make that single currency work
effectively by that I mean it didn't
have tight fiscal rules to discipline
member states it didn't have a bailout
mechanism for member states that
nonetheless got into trouble and it
didn't have a resolution mechanism it
assumed that the euro would drive
convergence between European economies
and sadly it did not and so far all
that's been devised is some temporary
solutions and significant further reform
is necessary let me try to amplify that
argument a little with a single interest
rate and no exchange rate options and
real competitiveness is very very
important to you there's no way out of
declining competitiveness via the use of
the exchange rate and unlike within a
single country like the u.s. you don't
have a significant central fiscal pot
which can offset changes in
competitiveness from place to place
this reality was concealed because for a
decade and what we had was what mervyn
king called a nice decade
non-inflationary and consistently
expansion and that covered a multitude
of sin to cover the multitude of sins in
financial markets as we've seen and it
covered a lot of underlying divergences
in the European Union and what we saw
during that period and was a remarkable
divergence in competitiveness between
European countries and in our view this
is the underlying problem in Europe and
not so much the deficits although the
deficits are to some extent a symptom of
that if you look at what happened to
competitiveness in the European Union
during the first decade this chart which
is perhaps the only slightly complicated
one I'll show has across the x-axis
export growth in relation to the euro
area average in other words if you were
on that central line your exports grew
during that period by precisely the
average of the euro area and the y axis
the vertical axis has changes in
exchange rates now you may say how can
that be is no exchange rate but this is
a unit labor costs measure as it changes
in unit labor costs during that period
and what you can see it not surprisingly
there is some inverse relationship if
your unit labor costs fell and your
exports grew more rapidly so in the
bottom right hand corner you can see
Germany the Germans who arguably joined
the single currency at a high exchange
rate many people thought that the French
had locked the Frank and the deutsche
mark inner two rather advantageous rate
for the French nonetheless reacted to
that challenge and through the German
tradition of mashed among and the
union's got together and decided they
would have low wage increases in order
to him enhance their competitiveness and
cope with this relatively high exchange
rate which they couldn't then change and
remarkably did had an increase in
exports of more than thirty percent more
than
european average during that period and
that competitiveness improved by fifteen
percent in relation to the average in
the top left-hand corner it is a
different story Italy Portugal Spain and
Greece saw their relative costs rise
rapidly and saw their export performance
significantly deteriorate and this was
not supposed to happen that the theory
of it was that if you locked countries
together with a single exchange rate and
more or less they would be obliged to
dance to the tune of the band leader who
was always regarded as the Germans that
it would be impossible if you locked
your country with the Germans to see
your competitiveness deteriorate sharply
but it did and it created significant
problems particularly for these
unfortunates the pigs Portugal Italy
Greece and Spain actually the pigs are
not it's not an exclusive club and
others can join the pig club and the
Economist in fact produced a rather
amusing reconstruction of Europe where
as you can see the UK now with our major
fiscal positions are situated quite
close to Portugal and Spain I sometimes
wish we were that would be rather good
from a weather climate tourism point of
view but in fact what you've had is some
rather significant changes within the
European Union on competitiveness and
that has had consequences for the fiscal
positions of some of these countries the
worst affected is Greece and Greece has
a particular problem because Greece
essentially reported deficits that were
significantly lower than the reality so
what this shows is the the blue lines
are the budget deficits that the Greeks
notified to the European Commission and
the red lines are what turned out
actually to be the case when the
European Commission went in and looked
at the books I am slightly embarrassed
to show this chart because during the
whole of this period and Greece the
finance ministers of greece were all
LSC graduates but there you are so
essentially what you have is a situation
which if of changing underlying
competitiveness which has generated in
some cases unsustainable deficits now
what do we do about this well if we have
to recognize that Aminu has always
really been essentially a political
project I mean it if you listen to the
defenders of he knew they will say no
that this is about removing the risk of
conflict in Europe and but there really
was a fundamental problem was that
without your own central bank it is
possible for a government even within a
single currency zone actually to run out
of cash and that's really what happened
to to to Greece I mean the Greeks can't
be can't be devalued you know there is
no drachma to devalue but the Greeks
essentially run out of cash no one was
prepared to lend to them anymore even
though they were theoretically part of
this euro zone and fiscal discipline was
seen to be a sort of desirable but not
really an essential element now one
interesting dimension of this just to
circle back through the central banking
problem before I come to what I think
may happen next is that as a result of
this and the structure of the ECB has
come under some pressure because the ECB
and has been pressed to deal with this
problem by intervening directly in the
markets and the ECB has been told well
it should go and buy Greek debt if
nobody else is prepared to do it and the
ECB of course was somewhat reluctant to
do that and this has created some very
dysfunctional relationships within the
European Union and the problem that has
been identified as well that the ECB
lacks very lack steer accountability it
has a very odd voting structure and it
is rather expensive
if you look at that in some detail this
just shows you the accountability
frameworks of central banks and their
independence the ECB is right in the
bottom right-hand corner it has a weak
accountability because there isn't
really an interlocutor now there isn't a
European economic government to hold the
ECB to account and it was given
extraordinarily high independence under
the Maastricht Treaty it also and this
is quite significant when it comes to
the role the ECB is now currently
playing has a very odd structure of
voting what this shows is a ratio of
regional to central votes and if you
look at the Fed position the Fed is
carefully constructed so that the FOMC
has a majority of votes at the center of
the Fed board in other words people who
are taking a view of the total position
of the US economy with some of the
regional feds having a vote but on a
rotating basis so they can never be in a
majority New York Fed unusual York Fed
President always has a vote but the rest
of them rotate so that produces a ratio
of regional to central banks of 0.7 to
one the old Bundesbank which is a
federal model as well had one point 1 to
10 but more or less a balance the ECB
has two point five to one in other words
each of the individual member states
even the small ones have got a vote and
there are only five members of the ECB
Directorate so there is in principle a
majority of small countries who can get
the ECB to act and I think it's not an
accident therefore that the ECB was
eventually pushed into buying Greek
bonds which the government's were not
prepared to do the ECB has been forced
to do it even though axel vapor the head
of the Bundesbank voted against and
indeed the Bundesbank directorate member
voted against so the central economy of
the european union was against doing
this but it nonetheless happened because
it was constructed with
very peculiar voting system with a lot
of votes in the periphery this has been
partially addressed in the sense that
it's not going to get worse but new
countries coming in it has now been
agreed and will not always have a vote
so when Estonia and Latvia joined they
will have a rotating votes like the
richmond fed but it will not correct
this very significant imbalance between
the regions and the center and it
creates a very remarkable difference
between voting rights and economic sighs
I mean quite different from what applies
in the in the US and this chart explains
to you why the Germans are to use a
technical phrase so Anstey about what's
going on because they are very very
significant obviously in the EU economy
and have a tiny voting weight which is
much much lower than their economic
weight so there's a very serious
structural problem in the ECB which was
constructed as something which didn't
really have central enough central
authority and was too much influenced by
the small member states and an example
of that really is that the ECB has never
actually managed to integrate central
banking if you look at the employees per
million inhabitants you've got 31
central bankers per million in the UK
and 68 in the US and then all of these
others are sort of additive so you've
got them in each individual country as
well as in the European system of
central banks you have a massively
costly regime which is creating
political trouble in fact they they have
these branches they still have branches
all over doing retail business but doing
it in a very peculiar way I was on
holiday recently in the South of France
in Avignon and in Avignon there is a
bank a branch of the bank of france
which does for an exchange business you
can actually go and still change notes
there and it has a splendid note on the
door saying this branch will close
noon or earlier if there is too much
business which is a wonderfully sort of
supply driven approach to how you think
about your customers because if you know
if there are too many people who want it
they'll close the door Elliot it but
it's extraordinary that central banks in
Europe are still doing this kind of
thing so but it's a symptom really of
the fact that the ECB does not have
enough power at the centre to assert
itself and to organize the system of
central banks in Europe so where are we
now well Greece has been rescued by the
EU in the IMF there is something called
the European financial stability
facility in place but it's supposedly
not intended for use and is only on a
three-year life many people now think
that this needs to be made permanent we
need more common fiscal Arrangements in
the European monetary union because they
there is this problem at the center that
it you can have countries that are Free
Riders but whose competitiveness
declines they offset that by
expansionary fiscal policy and then
eventually they have to be bailed out by
the others when people stop lending to
them this cannot continue there is now a
discussion group under the President of
the European Council producing new
fiscal rules some of them rather
dramatic proposals like that if your
budget deficit becomes above sixty
percent of GDP and you will lose your
voting rights in all European policy
making fora use a serious proposition
but that shows just how seriously people
are concerned about this problem
something needs to be put in place to
create some fiscal discipline on the
peripheral countries in the euro zone
but fundamentally there is still a
competitiveness problem and unless that
can be solved and unless these countries
that have lost competitiveness can
reform their labour markets particularly
then this is going to be a recurrent
problem so what's going to happen next
well there are as always in Europe the
most favourable option is muddling
through that's typically what happens
but this means I think there was going
to be continued austerity in the
southern countries and the Germans are
going to have to write some checks
otherwise this won't work this is of
course to keep the southern European
countries in the euro zone is a form of
vendor financing by Germany essentially
and that if they don't keep them in the
eurozone they will devalue dramatically
and stop buying German good so the
Germans in fact effectively our profile
providing them with finance to continue
to buy their exports and I suspect that
the Germans will still in the NC that
that is in their interests the
alternative are some kind of default at
the Greeks I think that's not impossible
that that might happen now in which case
that have to be significant losses but
the problem is that a lot of those
losses would fall on German banks and
French banks who have lent extensively
to Greece at the extreme one of my
economist has written the paper about a
possible breakup of the euro into two
currencies a euro and a midi for the
southern European countries this however
would be very painful from a European
point of view and I think it's not the
most likely outcome so I think what is
most likely is that we get continued
austerity in the southern countries this
will create some social problems that we
will have to have more central fiscal
policy and we will have to have bailout
arrangements within the eurozone which
essentially will have to be funded by
the wealthier countries in the middle
what about the UK well we remain on a
separate course we are outside the
European monetary union and it is likely
in my view that the resolution of this
mu crisis will involve more
centralization both in the ECB for the
reasons I've explained and fiscally that
will be extremely difficult for the UK
with a government which is committed to
no further
going to Brussels to accept so we will
accept it but we will only accept it for
eurozone members will say you want to
set up your own fiscal policy you do
that but we will not have anything to do
with it this will create a further
separation between the UK and the
eurozone and my conclusion is that we
will not join the euro in my lifetime
and I'm feeling quite well I always feel
well in New York a city I greatly enjoy
visiting I've enjoyed this occasion as
well and I now look forward to your
questions thank you
well thank you very much for that that
that great speech and we are going to
extend it send our time just a little
bit to allow some questions and answers
so if you if you want to ask a question
please approach one of the microphones
that are on the floor and while people
are getting ready for that I'm going to
just start off by asking one question
which has to do with of differences of
four central bank from monitoring or
targeting price stability and in
focusing on financial stability one of
the big problems in one of the big
differences between going after price
stability vs financial market stability
is that there's a there's a very large
difference in terms of the political
economy so I one can imagine the
difficulties that the Fed might have
faced in December of 2007 when Lehman
was trading at seventy dollars a share
and AIG look pretty healthy and if the
Fed had tried to step in and say Lehman
is a systemically important player needs
to be shut down the question one of the
questions is how do you regulate the
regulator how do you make sure that even
if you gave mandate to a central bank
that it will actually carry forward and
be able to deal with these very
politically connected powerful
institutions well and I think the best
answer to that question is that you
shouldn't have a bee in December 2007
and i guess the thrust of what i'm
saying is that you should be attempting
to respond and to these trends before
they get get critical but i think the
other part of my answer would be
that it would be very helpful if the
central bank had an explicit statutory
responsibility for financial stability
and that was articulated in its
publications with some kind of
definitions of what it meant and of the
risks and that I think helps you because
I think one of the problems that we saw
in the lead-up to the crisis was that it
was quite difficult for central banks to
act decisively and because they didn't
have a very clear mandate for doing so
they had a very clear mandate on retail
price inflation but they didn't have a
very clear mandate to cope with
financial stability now I have to say
that although this is unfashionable now
even in the UK that the framework that
was set up in the UK after 97 which
actually are now our new government
wants to change reason which I think are
wrong did create a more disciplined
accountability structure you know with a
regulator with a clear set of
responsibilities and accountability to
Parliament and their ability to sort of
blow the whistle with the central bank
as being the implementer of the support
if the regulator came along said look
this institution is in danger it needs
to be intervened on that is our
conclusion as its direct micro
prudential supervisor if you like and
then the central bank had to say yes ok
we agree with that and furthermore we
think that the risks for this
institution creating systemic problems
are such that we do think from our
perspective it's worth intervening and
then with the treasury sort of on top of
that because if it's a solvency issue
ultimately it's the Treasury writes a
check and not the central bank
personally I think that framework is
quite a an appealing one it didn't
actually work terribly well in the case
of the Northern Rock they mark I think I
own view because the Treasury didn't
control it properly and didn't really
understand the scale of the problem but
conceptually that seems to me to be
quite a good framework of policy a
regulator who is
sort of certifying at this institution
is in serious trouble and the central
bank who may sometimes say well that's
fine but they're just going to go out of
business and that's the end of it
because we don't think that they're
going to create systemic risk or else
saying yes ok we have your view that
it's going to go out of business and we
think that it needs to be rescued
because of the rest of the system and
that seems to me to create quite a good
counter balance and I rather prefer that
framework right thanks very much let me
now turn it over to the floor and I'm
going to try to prevent what they call
the new would be once referred to in a
New Yorker cartoon is following a long
speech by a series of short ones and try
to ask everybody to keep their questions
very short or the preambles very short
so maximize the number of people who can
ask and if you could just state your
name and your affiliation that would be
great Boris Nicholson school of
continuing education professor divis the
question is among the prominent
scenarios of the EMU resolution is there
one of the dissolution of the monetary
union and if the Union dissolves what
would be the provision for the holders
of euros outside of Europe would they be
able to exchange their euros or are they
going to be expecting a total loss thank
you do you have a lot of euro debt
yourself the there is a possibility and
I buy my third scenario a sort of euro
and a medi is actually in there there
are one or two pieces of paper on that
actually if you're interested in it have
been such a poor Charles good heart
who's from LLC and has written a short
paper on that subject and my own view is
it it's a long tail possibility i don't
think it's nil as a probability but i
think it's the costs of it would be so
difficult and that I think I think it's
by no means the most probable outcome
quite a bit of thinking has been done
actually in London as a group called the
Center for the Study of financial
innovation who have done some thinking
about what would actually happen
precisely on your point about euros now
it's actually very very complicated
because I think if it I think it's
pretty clear that if the Euro
instruments that you have in your
personal portfolio is a Greek government
issued euro-denominated bond and the
Greeks fall out of the eurozone well
you're going to get paid back in drag
map or whatever they go back to you're
not going to get paid in Euros and
similarly if it's a Greek headquartered
company then I think that's your
position what if you have a deposit in
euros in barclays bank in Athens what
what's that is that a Greek gyro or is
it a british euro or what is it and
nobody seems to be at all clear about
that so there's quite a lot of gray
areas about and what would be what would
be devalued if you like and there is
some work going on quietly in in London
by some fluke stack some people because
of the official sector got have anything
to do with it or not officially anyway
to work out precisely what a Greek gyro
might be because this was put together
as a marriage with no possibility of
divorce you know there was no prenup in
this which you can which you can look
back to but i think the sort of guiding
principle will be that if it's a bond
issued by an entity or the greek
government then it will be repayable in
in drachma and that's really why nobody
wants to hold these things and why the
only purchaser of Greek bonds at the
moment CCB over here hello my name is
Agatha rito-san I'm a student at
Columbia in the Masters and financial
engineering program and I just wondering
if professor Davis you could share your
views on competitive devaluation which
seems to be a hot topic at the moment as
to whether it's a good thing and if not
what's the way out are you asking me to
rule whether the u.s. is a currency
manipulator or not justice well I think
that you know if you have fundamental
competitiveness problems then clearly
one way of resolving them is by the
devaluation it's not painless because
you may well import inflation while you
do so and you may indeed remove the
discipline for domestic productivity
increases if you imply that you'll do
that every time so it's you know it's
not an easy option but it is one that
sometimes is inevitable and I suppose
looking at the position at the moment
between the US and China in particular
there looks to be a fundamental
imbalance there and something is going
to have to give on one side or the other
I prefer as I think it's a more
constructive way of looking at it to
consider this problem as a problem of
structural imbalances in both the US and
Chinese economy sort of mirror images of
each other with the US economy with the
over consumption if you like and the
Chinese excessively reliance on net
exports and on investment and I think
that if you look at it that way you can
see that in principle at least there is
a convergence of interest of the two
countries that it would be better for
the Chinese from a risk assessment point
of view if they could rebalance their
economy somewhat and it would on the
whole be better for the u.s. if some
resources could be switched out of
domestic consumption and particularly
out of property etc and into export
capacity would also be a useful
rebalancing in the the u.s. so I would
prefer to look at it that way than to
look at the symptom which is the
currency and which can create rather
dysfunctional rhetoric on both sides
which is you know at the moment looking
rather threatening and sort of slipping
us into potentially into trade Wars so I
think it's better to look at it in terms
of structural in
is in the economy rather than to look at
the exchange rate symptom over here good
evening Miguel maroon from the Economics
Department the European Union the spirit
was a union among equals how would you
design the ECB voting rights to take
into account GDP but avoiding the
southern countries at the periphery from
becoming an economic protectorate of
Germany and France hmm well I think that
you do need to move more towards the
u.s. model and and accept that monetary
policy and has to be made with the
interests of the whole of the eurozone
dominant so I think that you I think you
need more people at the center of the
ECB and working for the ECB Directorate
I either fed board equivalent as opposed
to the regional feds and at the moment
you have too few of them and there's no
reason of course why they shouldn't be
from other member states other than
generally indeed there's only one German
member of that so I would not say I mean
I think there's a probably the answer is
a combination of rotating voting for
some of the very small countries and
strengthening the center of the ECB at
the moment I think that the ECB is not
powerful enough in relation to the other
national central banks it was put
together on the basis that somehow you
just needed a small staff at the center
in Frankfurt and everything would be
done by the individual national central
banks and I don't think that's a in the
long run I don't think that makes sense
as a model so I be in favor of
strengthening the center as a European
institution as opposed to a German
institution you know it has to be a
pan-european institution but I don't
think that's I don't think that's
impossible so as I say a combination of
regional rotation and a strongest center
um
so we're a little over time so I'm going
to unfortunately have to bring this to
an end but you've met the man you can
now read the book copies are available
outside and I want to thank all of you
for coming and thank our speaker for a
fascinating talk very much